[Music]
in RESP CT trust me I'm a doctor I trust
you
here are five signs your partner doesn't
respect you oh [ __ ] let's find out
doesn't wear his wedding band to film he
would never do that the polisher she
would show her she's wrong Steve got the
polisher I don't need a ring to be man's
don't move your hands from that phone
you're a team and I know you always were
I always see it thank you Jim don't move
from that position you have it dude I'm
not on your team right it's also at the
polisher do men wear it on a right or
the left I'm just being paranoid
I must be really paranoid Gio that this
guy doesn't respect me and doesn't wear
and wouldn't wear that's not what I'm
telling Melissa anyway who cares you're
right I probably don't have anything to
worry about sure I saw her ad I'm chill
let's move on yeah women wear watches on
the right and on the left in the
beginning you were supposed to wear it
on the right but I think just like
working and [ __ ] when you write it gets
in them what do you know why women were
supposed to wear it on the right it's
not a thing I thought it was a thing did
you know wrist watches was a women's
thing not a men's thing men wore pocket
watches women wore wrist watches I
forgot why we my warm well I forgot why
it was always on the right but it moved
to the left or I guess whatever you
write with now I'm gonna give handjobs I
shaking too much from the other hands
it's easy thank you bar you always come
in with the correct man you know what
he's making all these sexual comments
Aziz what would eat the bread I'm
waiting your I'm waiting for there it's
like a catch-22 because the more he
makes these comments the less he's gonna
get it so taking yourself over Bart if
you have to time like what you're
writing
that's a Steve face look at this face
let's stop interrupting tip for one
[ __ ] second please just show us the
ring Vince that's what I've been trying
to do - I'm just trying to get tip I'm
just trying to get a good tip cut it
information out I note if studied a lot
you don't respect me what's the first
one I have one job holy [ __ ] I just
realized reddit is you ready ready
that's all we got for today goodbye
thanks for watching how many times have
you heard reddit toxin from the cat poop
for like 10 years what did you think it
was before I thought it was its own
thing like Nike but Google reddit Google
make up words Nike is a thing though I
know but it's not in present-day speak I
think God is a victory or something like
that oh it's a god here are the five
signs how to tell what if your
significant other respects you from a
therapist does not respect you oh yeah
sorry and therapist if you say it it's
like reddit the rapist that was on an
SNL sketch I don't watch SNL number one
well whoever you heard it from gut from
SNL no one in this room respects me by
the way I do hello I think that 1%
because number one is they speak over or
interrupt you I don't do it way way way
you even robbed me to pass I don't do
that oh yeah yeah no belt
yeah we always try to guess the end of
my sentence and it's always wrong
because he's trying to do the cute twins
I know it's cute but then sometimes a
lot of times he talks over me but it's
okay he's gotten better and he does that
to everyone
I know see don't think that see are you
trying to get laid by Steve what the
[ __ ] I'm trying to protect K's
protecting me from my own life I'm
trying to back them up cuz you don't
know what kind of a jam you have this is
topaz girl yeah no that's so she's
married to him homeboy but you gotta
appreciate cuz sometimes you don't
appreciate your apprecia you gotta
appreciate what you got got appreciate
what you got I like that there's no a.m.
you saying I don't appreciate don't take
it for granted that's what I'm saying
you saying I take it for granted is
don't take it for granted girl listen
man for [ __ ] sake and he's better than
that one that's for sure you don't know
what you've got until it's gone
I guess I'll continue being interrupted
didn't appreciate it but appreciate
appreciate appreciate Oh a appreciate
appreciated
there's no it's just no pre she let you
know you just tore up to her okay
interrupted it's a ruffed tip
interrupted can you girl alright number
two that should be a new Pig lies just
take the first letter
Bombur oh thank you oh my god I can't
even understand alright so they make
decisions for you that's a sign that
they don't respect you I thought that
means that that you love them cuz you
always want me to make decisions for you
what the [ __ ] like what they like you
should know that already you should
already made that decision for me hey
why are you because you should know it
so yeah it's I've already told you the
information now I expect for you to fly
like a bird yeah but it's not like you
don't know what I want and then you're
picking for me I must know what you want
but you don't know what you want Susan I
think that one's how we yeah cuz this
one says if your partner tends to make
small or large decisions like financial
or housing really that is [ __ ] up
without considering your yes or asking
you forget now that could be a warning
sign
yep that's huge I hate it would just
surprises me it just gets me soda I know
what did you why did you buy so I think
that's one oh it's a financial decision
I could purchase I wasn't a part of this
decision she has bought the soda without
me
what I mean girl she doesn't appreciate
you I wish she bought me the coke but
she got dr. pepper instead oh [ __ ]
what's wrong with her oh you're doing no
response after he just grilled me to
appreciate that's true you got a topaz
you under Jam you got a topaz not even a
diamond it's a topaz topaz much more
rare own meats you know diamonds are
artificially inflated
that's why I'll never call anyone a
diamond yeah number three you have to
make excuses for their behavior does it
for me all the time you always don't
animal I'm ghetto I think she lets you
dig your own hole yeah but you always
say yeah OS like hey can you please
excuse my husband pissing on the corner
that's wonderful okay that makes sense I
get it you don't respect my pissing that
means they're embarrassed of them yeah
abso-fucking-lutely dude and they make
excuses oh he's just got a stomachache
so he has to [ __ ] on the floor
Steve excuse my behavior is being cute
oh yeah
often because I have to it's a coping
mechanism you really won't see it don't
drown yourself speed dude you're
swimming in diarrhea if you're going to
hell you might as well swan dive yes man
I thought that's all I got to say I was
giving you credit and now you just just
you decided now don't want it don't want
a good sale now he's in debt yeah it's a
coping mechanism to him now you just
raise the interest on them all right
number four you do most of the
compromising that's not a good sign he
does most of the comfort I sure did it
mostly comfortable when you get to
people with big egos they both think
that they're always compromising
delusional he definitely does more of
the compromising we always think we're
compromising for the other one oh I do
it out of survival many times but I also
do it out of like who gives the [ __ ]
yeah he compromises more but he also
interrupts more so it's it's a balance a
balance oh they actually wrote to
protect Wow all right all right number
five they blame you for their action oh
[ __ ] oh yeah that was me never well you
get blamed I feel so bad for you bar he
blames me
oh I blame her made me do well I'm so
stable I'm so stable you pissed me the
[ __ ] up I put everything on it let me
consider gas lighting a little bit
what's gaslighting like when you make
the other person believe that they're
the ones that are no the fault they're
bad that's when you fart and you get a
matching and you light it up yeah by
still I should do that but just means
you're not accountable really yeah yeah
yeah yeah you try to put blame another
person for the
because it's so much easier it's so
easier when you don't have to change but
they do and then they make your life
easier that's the best way that's not a
healthy relationship what that's what
everyone wants
everyone wants to be agreed with and
understand
yeah like who wants to go through the
[ __ ] struggle of realizing that
you're actually a [ __ ] and you have
to [ __ ] make some sacrifices and
changes and not life is not easy like
who wants to do that no one does know
it's so much easier to find someone
that's like that just fits right into
your personality and does exactly what
the [ __ ] you want them to discuss mr.
Rogers told me I'm special so why is the
life easier answer for every bow it's
not yes it is what do you mean the
problem is mr. Rogers told everyone I
think mr. Rogers [ __ ] over a lot of
people I'm gonna continue to say it
whether it makes you uncomfortable or
not does it make me uncomfortable it's
just like she doesn't respect you Steve
he goes in when you're not the other
even though that that's a good theory
yeah I think so the mr. Rogers theory is
real he uses it for everything you use a
lot of things for everything to like
what
so when somebody mentioned getting sued
and watch what Mickey does no but I
don't I'm not saying that the problems
of being sued are the same reason every
time you know I'm saying you believe all
the problems on mr. Rogers neighborhood
conspiracy hat point no talking about
telling the seams to Isis is built by
mr. Rogers that's what I think I know
wait what's this about the reason 5
reasons why you should break up no these
are science signs that they why do you
need signs that someone does it respect
don't you just know I know what I don't
know that's true no when you're
disrespecting someone else not you I
think I don't care but a lot of people
are so passive isn't a relationship it's
not like it's not like you're with a
stranger it's something someone you
supposedly care about your partner let
me rephrase that
ok when I disrespect someone it's
because I'm mad no but we're
specifically talking about your
significant other a lot of people have a
low emotional intelligence
so they don't know when they're being
taken advantage of and so I think she'll
like this hope and I don't know what I'm
taking advantage of someone else I know
what I'm taking advantage of I don't
know what I'm saying about someone else
that's me at least you recognize it yeah
self-awareness that's what we all have
in spades that's the first step but you
know what I wish somebody told me this
[ __ ] sooner but you keep interrupting or
she's telling you no not that
Oh what because all of these things it
could be solved I wish someone told me
that [ __ ] sooner I wish someone told me
that there's someone else that's living
in here that wants to protect the
[ __ ] idea of what the world is and
never wants to change it and it [ __ ]
fights and makes you feel disgusting
inside emotionally if that world is
gonna get shattered damn this is like
I'm in his therapy session I love it I'm
here for the tea and then it fights and
fights and fights and it thinks it's
always right because it doesn't want to
be wrong ever because it's wrong that's
the [ __ ] dude I wish I could
pull this [ __ ] out of my ear
like it's a [ __ ] ear booger and then
I and I throw them out like that the way
you throw them out is by not identifying
with that anymore that's what I do
when it gets not so easy I agree it's
[ __ ] hard I'm just I breathe you
breathe I breathe too I breathe down to
my intestinal area I was like I
recognize that you're doing that but you
could have that argument by yourself
[ __ ] cuz I right now want a [ __ ]
cold watermelon and I sliced that
[ __ ] up and I will pass even
better than [ __ ] arguing with you
[ __ ]
are you is that your thought towards
Chesters that your thoughts would you
owe me is like water just walks into a
kitchen full of water knowledge she's
like I'm gonna go I'm not going to my
parents for a couple days
[Music]